this morning Democrat run Sanctuary
cities rocked by the growing migrant
surge this video from Boston's Logan
Airport join dozens of illegal
immigrants camped out with small kids
it's just like the scenes at Chicago air
airport where another 200 migrants were
camped out last month with nowhere else
to go our next guest calls an inhumane
and says the Biden Administration is
doing nothing to fix it Boston resident
and law student Jill Jacobson has been
kind enough to join us this morning Jill
you know not every city is a sanctuary
City so they don't have these migrants
there can you explain to our audience
what life is like and how you've been
impacted by
this good morning thanks for having me
yeah that's an interesting point not
every state is obligated to um undertake
what Boston and Massachusetts have
committed to do because Boston's
actually the only um massachusett is the
only state in the country that has the
right to shelter law so there is a legal
obligation to provide housing for these
individuals but uh Boston already is
amidst a huge housing crisis with its
lifelong residents we have a very tight
housing market here so we're legally
obligated to provide housing that
unfortunately we just don't have yeah so
I guess that begs the question Jill what
about the I mean we got high inflation
we got people that are living paycheck
to paycheck and we have a lot of folks
that are making ends meet if they're
taking care of all these migrants are
they able to take care of the average
day citizens that are
struggling yeah it's certainly put huge
pressure on our Administration on
taxpayers it's projected to cost almost
a billion dollars to handle the migrant
crisis the average price of a
one-bedroom in Boston Massachusetts has
exceeded $3,000 and and that's for
lifelong residents which is why we're
seeing all of our shelters at Max
Capacity and unfortunately incoming
migrants being forced to sleep at places
like Logan Airport Jill I know in
politics it's hard to decipher who's
responsible but who do you think
residents and residents like yourself
blame for this
crisis yeah I think sometimes in
politics it's difficult to discern who's
responsible but it is surely not in this
situation this is a federal government
created problem right the governor of
Massachusetts the mayor of Boston they
are not down at the southern border this
is the Biden administration's making and
unfortunately it's been put on state and
city governments to solve despite the
fact that it was created by the federal
government I know Governor Healey has
reached out to the Biden Administration
multiple times asking for assistance and
uh her requests have largely fallen on
deaf years unfortunately Jill if you had
the opportunity I guess to talk to the
president president or someone within
the administration because they think
that this allowing people to come this
is just compassion so what would you
tell them to counter
that yeah I would say you know to me it
is morally hazardous to call this sort
of behavior compassionate because you
convince yourself that an open borders
immigration policy for example is
compassionate because everyone deserves
the American dream for example and you
know we live in a great country I would
hope that everyone gets the opportunity
to contribute to it uh and be here it's
a great place but the problem is when
they arrive here they're not getting the
American dream we do not have the
administrative capacity to process work
permits we don't have housing they end
up in really uh horrible conditions like
sleeping in Logan Airport without
showers or food and it's really really
cold in Boston and and they don't have
anywhere to go largely so I would say
you know let's get honest this is not
compassionate um and and let's be really
realistic about the capacity that we
have and the opportunities that we can
provide and the opportunities that
unfortunately we cannot provide right
now it it's such a valid point you
invited people to come to the country
illegally you have no place for them
they're freezing in the cold you got
people that are drowning every single
day in the Rio Grant trying to come
across the border that's not
compassionate uh Jill thanks I do want
to be clear it it is an invitation I
mean the bid Administration has said
come on in and and these people largely
view it as that which I think is a
really important and concerning part of
the equation such a critical point Jill
thanks so much for joining the program
thanks for having me I'm Steve duy I'm
Brian killme and I'm Angley Airhart and
click here to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling
analysis